[Musik]
wir sitzen am schnittplatz in zürich als
wir von unserem reporter kollegin
christa franzen dem früheren russland
korrespondenten eine e mail erhalten
ein russischer oppositioneller habe auf
facebook dieses bild gepostet
die russische armee soll solche mobilen
krematorien mit sich führen um die
eigenen toten fortlaufend zu verbrennen
und damit zu verhindern dass zu hause
sehr gern kommen
wenn jetzt aus erklärte krähe geht mit
vielen russischer toter
soldaten aber viele tote in der
ukrainisch zivilbevölkerung und adobe
die härtere sanktionen oder ihr könnt
ihr hättet ausführliches fehlen sie ich
könnte mir vorstellen dass in der
bevölkerung stimmen gekippt wie wird
denn der aktuell ich getragene
bevölkerung erklärt
stand jetzt ist dass searchmetrics
sondern eine militärische
spezialausstattung
von donezk und logan
freitagabend in moskau
am zweiten tag des krieges wird im büro
des srf die nächste live schaltung nach
zürich vorbereitet
christof franzen verfliegt derzeit die
aktuelle russland korrespondentin lucia
tschirky die sich zu diesem zeitpunkt in
der ukraine befindet mehrmals täglich
ordnete die neuesten entwicklungen für
das schweizer publikum ein
tester fanden in moskau in diesem film
soll es auch um die hintergründe dieser
eskalation gehen zusammen mit christof
franzen wollen wir die handy bilder die
uns derzeit aus der ukraine erreichen
einordnen
wir wollen mit menschen reden die vor
diesem krieg fliehen
[Musik]
wir wollen ihnen eine stimme geben die
da geblieben sind
[Musik]
christof franzen versucht wieder in
kontakt zu kommen mit dem ukrainer
alexej der seit acht jahren freiwillig
an der front ist
[Musik]
und wir wollen zeigen was das alles mit
dem weiteren protesten aus dem jahr 2014
zu tun hat
hattest du je für möglich halte dass der
vladimir putin der ukraine weiter offen
wir erklären
die option tatsächlich immer von der
logik gerade einmal ist an solchen
erwarten dass das früher oder später mal
passiert will wenn denn die ukraine so
wichtig ist wenn er wirklich verhindere
dass gewitter nach letzter ab trifft der
hätte was sinologe alles besser machen
aber was man hätte ich huste war das
wird die verursacher aber vor allem mit
einer sanktion ist hätte das für viel
hätte die sanktionen da schlechte fonds
kommen die sind mannshoch also im
schloss wirkliche marschiert das ist für
viele überraschend
was kaum jemand für möglich gehalten
habt ist nun realität
[Musik]
wenn die videos deren herkunft sich
meist nicht überprüfen lässt geben einen
eindruck von diesem krieg
von eingekesselten städten die unter
beschuss stehen und vom leiter
zivilbevölkerung
[Musik]
die zweitgrößte stadt der ukraine noch
zu friedenszeiten
hier haben wir peter werden vor sechs
jahren zum ersten mal getroffen
der berner bauernbub und gelernte
mechaniker hat ein café imperium
aufgebaut das in den besten zeiten
2500 angestellte beschäftigte
mit dem import von kaffee hat er hier
ein vermögen gemacht
außerdem hat er eine landesweite kette
mit kaffeehäusern aufgebaut
heute ist er wie hunderttausende auf der
flucht
jetzt zwölf stellen der gefahr caroni
liess krementschouk minute erzwungen
es wäre thomas vecsey frau maclean
schenkt
auf der autobahn habe es stundenlange
staus gegeben erzählte
unterwegs seien chemischen gruppen
begegnet die hätten alle zivilisten
passieren lassen wo die detonationen zu
sind zu
hause sehr überrascht
als ich angst
naja
der wohlstand ist also schleppt die
ceausescus mix karton stecken
es doch mit komischen wie rechtsgebiete
schon keine angst
sie werfen ihr eigentlich sehr
wahrscheinlich dass das aber die ukraine
und russland sieht in den jüngsten
erfahrungen
hier lebte wir mut bis vor einigen
jahren zusammen mit seiner damaligen
partnerin und ihren vier kindern
[Musik]
bis sechs
ja jetzt der größte bestätigung
das älteste der kinder der inzwischen 18
jährige sascha schickt uns dieses video
[Musik]
zusammen mit seinen geschwistern hat er
sich in den keller unter einem von
währungsgeschäften geflüchtet
denn der krieg kommt horcoff erreicht
hans jürgen stumpf sind
die kinder sollen bei ihr bleiben habe
seine ex partnerin tatjana gesagt
ja die
mögliche chance linie
die
kriegs-
oder
wohngebiete schließt das werk in dem
ganze drum bass oder das ist aus kaputt
gemacht wurde vor denen große
kämpfe chenault und wurde
der 18 jährige sascha macht für uns
dieses video und wagt sich später sogar
aus dem keller und mit uns zu sprechen
[Musik]
wer den kauf keinen sicheren keller
gefunden hat er verstand sich derzeit in
einer u-bahn-station
[Musik]
können sie sagen wir haben sie das
erlebt aus dass angefangen hat in der
nacht von mittwoch auf donnerstag
das hat ja das war so weißt du wie eine
ikone du verstehst nicht was sie reden
hat einfach mal aufgemacht
ungefähr 16 und gesagt so jetzt machen
die top spiel dann habe ich so schnell
so tief was ich kann so
geschützt die großen alles was ich ganz
schnell ab und kommt jetzt auf kommen
jetzt
können sich
so in schuss
dann friert das bild ein wir hoffen dass
wir später wieder erreichen können
von moskau aus versucht christof franzen
mit dem ukrainer alexej kontakt
aufzunehmen
hallo ich bin's christoph hallo wie geht
es steht so gott sei dank
alle am leben
im moment ja
acht jahre vorher in kiew die
sogenannten bei den protesten
er hat christof franzen alexej zum
ersten mal getroffen aus der gerade die
leiche eines demonstranten hier getragen
hatte
er stand neben mir auf der barrikade
dann hat ein scharfschütze ihm in die
lunge geschossen gerade erst vor zehn
minuten
[Musik]
als wir ihn wegtrugen sagte er noch
verdammt ich will nicht sterben
[Musik]
christoph war gesicht vor dem heutigen
web verstehe ich glaube dann muss mit
druck logan auf anfang 2014 auf die
stars wobei dann passierte die
wörthersee und was hat das für eine
partie so genannt die medienrevolution
radfahrer bis frühjahr 2013 herrscht
dort mal hinter dem trainer eigentlich
weil er die vertrag mit der europäischen
union an zeichner also einen
freihandelsvertrag und auszuziehen
vertrag und da hat russland ganz viel
druck gemacht aber finanzielle angebot
gemacht dass die vertrag nicht
unterzeichnet und schlussendlich hatte
damals hochrhein ist präsident der
viktor janukowitsch entschied dass die
vertrag nicht unterschrieben und da sind
die mannschaft straßgang auf der meile
und die ganze meute und protesten
empfangen
auf den strassen kiews verlangten
hunderttausende dass die ukraine auf
ihrem europäischen kurs bleiben sollte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der präsident reagierte zunehmend mit
polizeigewalt
[Musik]
als folge davon versammelten sich
radikale demonstranten auf dem acker an
unter ihnen auch bewaffnete
[Musik]
am 18 februar 2014 begann die polizei
mit der räumung des platzes
die situation eskalierte zwei tage
später schossen scharfschützen auf die
demonstranten die regierung standort
braun
das ist kein bürgerkrieg erschießen
nicht brüder auf brüder getötet die
polizei ihre eigenen bürger
nach diesem drama beugte sich präsident
janukowitsch dem internationalen druck
und er versprach neuwahlen
dann aber flüchtete er nach russland
auf druck der strasse oder
fallengelassen von seinen
sicherheitskräften
das berufen
das ukrainische parlament wählte
daraufhin eine übergangsregierung
da hätte natürlich mit mikronährstoffen
jetzt hohe kräne in richtung westen tu
und lehrern einmal in
moskau sprach von einem faschistischen
hund und einem staatsstreich
russland hat die wälder dass die ukraine
ihre
institutionen mitmachen und wenn nach
erneuter und proteste hat der ist vom
westen finanziert das ist ein
antirussischer protest und wenn die
nachgeschichte ereignis zuspitzt hängt
und der präsident janukowitsch ist
flüchtet nach russland und den pro
westlichen
regierung schaut macht er hätte
astrologie mit putin also große
niederlage empfunden und was hat der
tour ausgeschlossen
der fesche reaktion ist nach sie das
mode krebs setzt hat
auf der ukrainischen halbinsel krim
tauchten soldaten und abzeichen auf
wer sie geschickt hatte wurde allerdings
schnell klar
egal tags aktion bezeichnet das aktions
petzschner war einfach traumhaft
genützt hat sich darüber die planen die
cremes sätze die sind für ihn schon der
schublade achse wie hätte welchen auf
das reagiert auf die annexion vor dem
damals ich das für den westen ganz
großer schock sie mal etwas nicht
erwartet hat amazon stadträte diesem
völlig überrascht sie der mit dem dekra
hat man halt nicht wissen wir mit dem
umbau aber bereits mit sanktionen
probiert
wenn wir diese aktion hätte euro zurück
wird muss man sagen was ihr schwach sind
und eigentlich in russland nicht nur um
den krieg führt
die ukraine kam nicht zur ruhe nun
eskaliert es auch im osten im dom was
einst sowjetische stolz hochburg der
kohlebergwerke und schwerindustrie
bewaffnete separatisten besetzten
verwaltungsgebäude
anhänger der ukrainischen einheit lebten
jetzt gefährlich hunderte wurden
entführt teils gefoltert oder sogar
ermordet
viele köpfe der separatisten kommen aus
russland und russische demonstranten
kamen busweise in die ukraine
gewählte ukrainische politiker mussten
weichen
selbsternannte volkstribun ii traten an
ihre stelle
schwerem kriegsgerät auf unter ihnen
ehemalige
spezialeinsatzkräfte von ex präsident
janukowitsch aber
auch viele russen und tschetschenen
es hat damals in rostock und frida
hacker liegt aber das quartier um street
hätten schnee so groß sie dass das hatte
zum reiseführer
tausende verlangten in jenen tagen
mussten die abspaltung von der ukraine
[Musik]
[Applaus]
eigentlich eine minderheit wie umfragen
zeigten
[Musik]
aber diese minderheit was sie präsent
gebaut wurde die unabhängigkeit der
region donetsk und lugansk verkündet
die stimmen hatten die seperatisten
selbst ausgezählt eine farce
das massive jahr wurde weder von kiew
noch international anerkannt
[Musik]
dass sich russland am anfang vor allem
mit ihrer propaganda
sondergleichen und problem ist aber
sieht das neu in der ost ukraine vor
allem die russische fernsehsender
erfolg wirkt und nach
der
unterstützung für separatistische kraft
und irgendwie hatte ich das immer
zugespitzt demonstrationen hinter noch
anheizt erster schuss kts der toten nach
dem hattrick von
ukrainischen übergangsregierung schickte
die armee in den dom bass
diese war in einem desolaten zustand
[Musik]
im umgang mit ihren prorussischen
landsleuten waren die kurzfristig
aufgebotene soldaten überfordert
das war die stunde der ukrainischen
freiwilligen bataillonen
verbände nationalistischer kämpfer von
denen viele schon ihren durchhaltewillen
auf den mai angezeigt hatten
hier traf christof franzen alexej wieder
der familienvater um kleinunternehmer
oder seiner heimatstadt im westen der
ukraine angereist
alexej hatte zu haben sie ein kleines
lastwagen unternehmen sein
zwillingsbruder vertrat ihn dort
trotzdem musste er von der front aus
ständig mithelfen
viele dieser kämpfe hatten vor ihrem
einsatz keine militärische erfahren
[Musik]
schießt schnell je länger du zählst
desto schwieriger wird es
der nächste kampf kann jede minute
losgehen sie können jederzeit anrufen
und sagen ab in den kampf und dann geht
es los
[Musik]
und bist du jetzt
ich bin nahe der russischen grenze
ja mit dem kämpfst du in welchem
portfolio
ich bin daran eine partisanen gruppe
aufzubauen
oder einen mächtigen gegner
wir werden hier alle beerdigen bei uns
ist alles klar
dass du auch die seele gekämpft
eigentlich ja
insgesamt war ich wohl ein jahr daheim
ich habe mich um die firma gekümmert da
ist alles gut wir heute arbeiten
acht jahre dauert der konflikt im
donbass inzwischen an
2018 besuchte christof franzen die
region letztmals zusammen mit osze
beobachtern
eine zeitlang flügel hier ständig die
granaten ums haus herum habe ich schon
38 einschläge gezählt der hof und alles
ist kaputt nur mein sohn und ich
bete sieht die schützengraben und das
sind ziemlich fix ii positionen und je
nach der politisch konjunktur hat nur
fern und mehr oder weniger geschossen
aber derart wien oder so heitz braucht
es keine mekka das ist also nicht ein
krieg sie warum land kraft hat sondern
einfach um politische vorträge
2015 hatte noch alles nach einer
friedlichen lösung ausgesehen dank dem
minsker
waffenstillstandsabkommen
vertrag war der
separatisten in rohstoffe jene ganz
große zu überstimmen geheimnisse machen
mit einer vertrag hat russland gewonnen
und auch die sache so dass die vertrag
nicht sind umgesetzt wurde also von der
russischen internet aber aber der
ukrainisch sind russland einfach geraten
karte und immer wieder mal eskalierte
kampf in der hoffnung die ukraine rechts
kupfer aber die in mittlerweile opfer
sind parallel dazu
immer prowestlicher wurde ich immer mehr
in die europäische wirtschaft integriert
wenige geschafft mit russland
und es ist möglich dass letzten putin
elf hektar wird wenn jetzt die ukraine
zu cola des nachts sport
am 24 februar
2022 bevor der russische präsident den
einmarsch in die ukraine das war
seither gibt es luftangriffe
durch markov die zweitgrößte stadt der
ukraine rollen panzer
trotzdem gelingt es uns den 18 jährigen
sascha wieder zu erreichen
[Musik]
mit raketen von die grenzen haben
wenn wir haben nicht ans mindestens
zeigt dass wir haben so
viel anhaben
lasst sie kommen mario pohl der ganze
drum bass und unser heiliges römisches
land wird euer grad willkommen in der
hölle ruhm der ukraine
dank wlan bekommt sascha solche videos
die der zeit und der ukraine passieren
die botschaft wird kann so zu den waffen
greifen und sein land verteidigen
[Musik]
weil uns haben schon eine gesetz
gesetz gemacht wo alle leute ab 18 bis
60 jahren müssten mobilisiert sein und
zu verteidigen gegen russland ich
verstehe dass sich das sterben aber ich
weiß dass meine familie und meine
freunde
die haben gestorben
die hände seien die haben gestorben für
die
internationale beobachter sind
beeindruckt vom widerstandsgeist der
ukraine
putins armee scheint langsamer voran zu
kommen als sich das der cremo
vorgestellt hat dazu kommen
nachschubprobleme weil sie kein benzin
mehr haben müssen diese russen zu fuß
weiter
[Musik]
der ukraine
die minen vergraben geh nach hause
unsere kinder rennen herum
geht lebendig wieder nach hause
dieser krieg an sich noch lange
hinziehen wie viel leid der
zivilbevölkerung noch bevorsteht ist
nicht absehbar
[Musik]
du kannst ja russland sehr gutes video
über das land berichtet die aktuellen
ereignisse die irgendwie den blick auf
russland erschüttere infrage stelle
ja ich bin sehr tüchtig was jetzt
passiert also ich hatte zwölf jahre in
dem land knapp meine freunde sind alles
doppelbürger und ich hatte mir natürlich
ganz besonders russland gewünscht und
ich glaube russland weißrussland
des stolzes land sie genau wie jetzt
aber auf ein anderer weg
rechtsstaatlicher erfolg wichtig für das
ist ja so 6 position in dem land das ist
so viel
couragierte junge zwei bestellte machen
war was sind meine kollegen
und
ich das gefühl die brüder und der krieg
nicht das ist das ist völlig hirnrissig
jetzt das ganze mit dem was jetzt
passiert da wird haus schüler auf jahres
für lisa dafür zehnte das für eine
enttäuschend
[Gelächter]
und die ukraine was dieser krieg für die
ukraine und in selbst bedeutet dass wir
christoph ronson von alexei wissen der
gerade an der front steht
[Musik]
meine kinder wissen nicht wie man ohne
krieg lebt
aber meine groß kinder haben eine große
chance zu leben ohne zu wissen was
krieges
du kannst jetzt feige sein und später in
sklaverei sterben ich will nicht dass
meine kinder so leben wie man in
russland in weißrussland oder in
nordkorea liegt
ihr leben muss seinen sinn haben darum
ist es das schicksal der ukraine diesen
weg zu gehen
doch unser blut finden wir wahre
freiheit
[Musik]
zum schluss etwas positives
peter wer mut hat es geschafft er ist
zurück in der schweiz
dass er persönlich sehr gut
ja natürlich das scheue vor der tat über
sicheres gefühl dass mehr zeit bleibt da
in charkow
diese art ist schweiz ist natürlich auch
so häufig sie ja darum geht wo aus
miterlebt
dass die mit traumatisierten
vier tage waren unterwegs er sei gerade
noch rechtzeitig losgefahren
bevor die russen ihm den fluchtweg
abschneiden konnten
[Musik]
ist eigentlich dieses wirtschaftlich als
war
machine nicht ganz so wohl dass im
ganzen netz von deinen traum coffees so
viel aktiver und und was das ist für
agrarpolitik
echt usd fällig was sie treffen versetzt
hat scheinbar wohngebiet die bombardier
kriegsverbrecher
kann natürlich schon viel kaputt wird
aus darum mache sich große sorgen um die
kinder
euro kredit im kmu
machen die ukrainische armee doch
das leichteste traum vorgestellt als
jüngst um die finden
das klappt muss erzählen dann relativ
gut vertrauen dass tennet einem chor und
passiert aber mit zum beispiel für die
partnerin volvo jetzt die ricola
tour-tag fangen vertreibt die ukraine
der brite ist richtig von basra china
montage ten also groß erwies und so
weiter die panzer über
panzer cup
wo die sie besitzt privater wo sie nach
oslo aus gründen das war aus direktorin
des ewig unwahrscheinlich dass die
erlauben was die machen den models
[Musik]